Reggie Miller Hall of Famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst on the call Thursday
night Mavs
Knicks at the Garden I should go down
there they probably don't want me there
after the things I just said about the
next situation Reggie Miller joining us
reg can you hook us up for Thursday
night at the garden I cannot wait to see
the Knicks how can you go into Dallas
obviously a hyped game because you were
playing against christos porzingis yeah
and when and then lose by 30 plus the
next night or two nights later versus
the Cavaliers that's that's the problem
with the Knicks I mean its head
scratching and I know they say they're
rebuilding and young that it's from the
optics
it just doesn't look good but reg even
if they're rebuilding and they're young
then why the possibility of firing David
fizz Dale wouldn't you keep fizz Dale to
help with the growth and let this play
out a little bit and have some stability
absolutely and a lot of these players
that they either have drafted or traded
for I'm sure he had a hand in selecting
so there's another reason why to keep
him around to develop you know the
veterans like Julius Randle Taj Gibson
you know veteran leadership that can
help some of these young players but the
problem I see with the Knicks is with
most young teams but the young teams in
today's game at least they play hard
they might lose games because of
experience but at least they play hard
the Nick the Knicks and their young
players at times it doesn't even look
like they are trying and that's the
problem I have is the effort I don't
care if you're losing but give the
effort do you think David finsdale is
coaching on Thursday when you do that
game I do okay I do I think it'd be a
rash decision to get rid of Thursday I
believe he'll be there Thursday but
again Daniel as you know it's the Knicks
but Reggie
if you were a free agent would you
consider the Knicks now no okay because
because you know we heard this from
Durant where we thought I thought all
along he was gonna end up with the
Knicks and then he said they're not
relevant so today's player doesn't know
what we know of what the Knicks used to
be and they're looking at that and like
it's a great place to play but it's not
a great team to play for and in today's
game in any sport really you don't have
to be in a major market to still have to
help your brand because a lot of these
young players there a lot of them are
just worried about their brand Theodore
you know that it's all about commercials
and looking good in TV games and you
know how many likes we're getting on
Instagram so you don't need to be in New
York Chicago LA anymore you know when we
had LeBron in Cleveland he was obviously
our number one star in one of the
smaller markets and he thrived in that
so you don't have to be in a major
market the Knicks aren't what they used
to be in the 90s and you know you
wanting to play in the mecca and you
know having the stars and celebrity it's
not that anymore right
so I agree with Durant but I will say
this it will always be a Knicks town
though because of the history until
Brooklyn wins something what do you make
of the the Raptors beat the Lakers at
the Lakers what do you what do you make
of that that Toronto is better than
people have given them because you lose
Kauai and then you have injuries to Kyle
Lowry Serge Ibaka
but ASCO Sock'em who showed us glimpses
yeah when it was kalaiy last year all we
kept talking about was kowai kowai kowai
knee can leave you look at pascal see
Ockham's numbers they were fantastic
throughout the whole playoffs and he has
emerged as their go-to guy so this is a
prideful team they're well coached by
coach nurse and they've got guys Fred
vanvleet again second-round pick for
your letterman
Wichita State knows how to make big
shots they've kind of tinkered a little
bit of that starting line up bringing in
Norman Powell you still got pal Gasol
who was the Defensive Player of the Year
so they still have an identity and they
have that championship DNA so am I
surprised no it was a back-to-back it
was a good game last night versus the
Clippers versus Kauai and his former
team I just think they ran out of gas
but the Raptors
nicholae are still a pretty good team
Lakers can't lose it home to the Raptors
when their two guys down I mean yeah but
I mean here's the thing
the Lakers everyone they're on top of
the world because they go on that road
trip and they be Dallas to beat San
Antonio there's triple doubles flying
out the windows for LeBron and they come
home and lose the game now everyone
think this is the end of the world
come on this team is sitting on top of
the Pacific Division or tide and they're
playing well and they're 10 games in and
they're still figuring out I know ATS
having some kind of which shoulder donor
you know situation he's not a 100% and
they're still finding ways to win
ballgames let's address the Lakers and
all these other teams come Christmas Day
and those games going into the new year
because you got to give a sample size of
20 to 25 games that's who you are that's
how you're gonna play unless you had you
know free agents or injuries happen to
your team's pretty much that's going to
be your DNA the rest of the year so we
got another 10 games or so to go for the
Lakers to really start to judge them and
see what they're going to be for the
rest of the season man I caught a lot of
grief from from people including you a
little bit with you know my take that
LeBron is still better than Kawhi and my
point is Kawhi is a wonderful postseason
player he never had a triple-double and
you know LeBron plays more minutes and
more games he's more valuable to his
team than Kauai as Kauai is wonderful in
the postseason LeBron is still a better
player why is this you know a topic of
discussion or anger or arguments
well because everyone tried to compare
you know Kobe and you know so many other
players to Michael Jordan everyone's
trying to compare players to LeBron he's
the best player of this generation so
that's what we do but between you and I
it wasn't so much
who's better because I told you LeBron
will always have the numbers because he
will have the games the minute you're
right about the triple doubles but in
terms of coming towards the playoffs
when right now you know the whole topic
last week or the last 10 days was load
management which is driving me crazy
you're gonna see that from the from
Kawhi he's not gonna play either the
first two back-to-back so the second
game of back-to-backs because he is
gearing up so towards the playoffs and
what is more important to have your best
player on full gas for the playoffs or
running on fumes running into the
playoffs not that LeBron is going to be
running on fumes but that's just how
Kawhi works and it worked last year for
them but it doesn't always work because
if I remember right JoEllen bead was on
load management and work out very well
for the Philadelphia 76ers right yeah so
you you know pick your poison it goes
both ways but Kawhi can't be the MVP reg
if you're playing a game right I agree
he can't be high great okay no can't be
I agree whatever is in he can't be but
that wasn't the question who was gonna
be the MVP you're asking who would I
pick right now regular season I would
pick LeBron postseason fresh I'm gonna
pick quiet just because of the load
management because he'll be who played
the most minutes during the playoffs
last year Kawhi Leonard okay
I mean look he I can't argue with how he
closed out with the Spurs winning a
championship and in Toronto like I can't
argue with that
he had a banged up Warriors team but you
know what he still did what you want a
great player to do I just I keep telling
people you know LeBron has never really
gotten the credit that he deserves I I
know that may sound like a hot take but
I still think we we have
looked at LeBron for all the things that
he doesn't do or didn't do or couldn't
do on the floor instead of celebrating
what he was able to do we didn't do that
with magic didn't do that with Larry
didn't do that with Mike but with LeBron
I
I think he's the first you know true
superstar that we really looked at
through a negative lens a lot of people
did and I don't know why you know you
went to my a lot of it I think a lot of
probably people assumed too much too
soon
you know the cover of Sports Illustrated
when he was what you know sixteen seven
rating something like that and the
chosen one and that probably rubbed
people the wrong way when you still had
this players you just mentioned still in
the game like Michael Jordan and I think
magic was just retiring and so people
are like the chosen one you know the guy
you know the king the King you know that
probably rubbed people the wrong way but
I do agree with you because I don't know
if I could put them on my Mount Rushmore
but he's knocking on the door right I
mean it he's probably you and I had this
conversation about the best small
forward of all time it was hard for me
to relinquish Larry Bird it just it's
hard for me but it's hard for me not to
put LeBron ahead of him it really is
well bird at his best to me was better
than LeBron at his best it and once
again these aren't for hot takes because
I don't do that but when when bird
averaged thirty ten and ten like his
best season was better than LeBrons best
season and you know bird was winning
championships as well you know I don't
think I don't think bird first of all
birds never made it to 17 17 years no no
bird wouldn't be bird wouldn't be able
to even in birds last year which I think
it was 12 or 13 years he wasn't playing
like how LeBron is playing right now and
his 17th year oh no you know but bird
was had a bad back for probably you know
latter half of his career last four
years of his career
don't you have to factor that in a
little
oh no he's not better than LeBron I'm
saying bird at his best is better than
LeBron at his best he's a better shooter
he's a better passer he's a better
rebounder my guy you know how much I
love Larry legend Larry Joe yeah it's
just you're talking about the best small
forward of all time I'll give that to
the brunt but not in if I take LeBrons
best year in Larry's best year I'll take
Larry over him and imagine if you had
today's three-point philosophy yeah I
mean he just he he's better at his best
than LeBron is but LeBron is gonna be
considered a greater player and I have
no problem with that
not at all you've got Luca dhansak
coming up on Thursday night I watched
him against the Celtics last night and
I've said this to this audience
basketball is about angles it's about
getting leverage it's about finding
space it's about getting somebody
uncomfortable you know where you can
take advantage of them off balance I
mean you understood this as well as
anybody
Don chick who's not even 21 understands
angles reg that it he plays like he's 10
years older than what he is you know I'm
assuming he is really 20 but McLovin
says I may tell you why it's because
they're playing professionally since he
was what 14 or 15 yeah so he knows those
angles by playing against older players
and developing those angles when I watch
him play there are such a smoothness to
his game because you could never really
rattle or speed them up he controls the
pace of game and at that size and to
have that pittypat and the separation he
you know we talked about James Harden
step back and how much space he creates
Luca is in that same category if not
better in terms of step back and when
you've got a jump shot that pure and
you're able to handle the basketball
like that and you've got shooters on the
edges to me that's why Dallas is one of
those teams that are on the rise is
because of Luca obviously we had
porzingis at that size who could stretch
the floor well coach obviously a former
coach of mine and Rick Carlisle but he
is a truly truly special player because
of the angles
you mentioned McLovin went on a rant a
little while ago about the officiating
on James Harden and he for some reason
thinks the officials are giving Hardin
the benefit of the doubt with all these
free throws here is that is that a fair
characterization thirds are up 80
percent this year he's done breaking
every NBA record he's gonna break the
record by a mile for most free throws
made in this season okay are they giving
him preferential treatment and I believe
he just broke the most free throws
attempted for the first ten games of any
player in NBA history
yeah will Chamberlain held that record I
put him in that same category as Michael
Jordan because Michael Jordan got fouled
on every play we I I tripped hit slip
you didn't like Jordan to try to stop
them and you just you really put it on
the officials like they can't call
everything because he's getting fouled
on every single play you say the same
thing about James Harden as much as he
dribbles and isolations and 101 and yeah
he creates a lot of space with a little
bit of that chicken jab but he is
initiating a lot of the contact a lot of
times and it's hard to officiate so I
think a lot of times he gets the benefit
of the delts because he's initiating
that he I put him in the same boat as MJ
because they can't call every foul
so they gets a lot of the benefit of
doubt calls from the official man if he
gets that three-point shooting
percentage up again oh boy
close in on average in 40 I mean he's
averaging 36 now reg 37 3 to being again
I like to sample size of 20 games or so
but weren't like 10 games in it had to
pick an MVP right now are you going with
Harden are you going with you honest oh
I'm not going Harden no I mean I've seen
he's wonderful player I just don't know
if they're any better this year than
they were last year with Chris Paul I
mean III need to see a little bit more
with that team and they're guaranteed to
disappoint seven threes and top three or
four Yanis there
top two or three they're seven and three
but numbers wise numbers lies between
the two unbelievable I'm gonna go ye
honest with you I probably would too
I and Dame Lillard had sixty the other
night reg and lost I know and lost they
they don't look the same as they did
last year and I don't know I can't
really put a finger on it because they
play the same way I know they lost some
key role players but they just don't
look the same they don't have that same
fight to them as they did last year last
year they were the underdog and you know
they were going after the teams that you
know had the bullseye on their back this
year they're kind of the hunted you know
after the success they had of getting to
the conference finals they just don't
look the same
that's a great point do you want to
weigh in on bad guys and movies we root
for I do um look I grew up I'm a huge
I love the Western Washington with my
dad so there's two that come to mind
I always rooted for Billy the Kid right
I know he wasn't a great guy and robbing
banks and you know shoot him up but I
loved Billy kid number one but my
probably my all-time favorite guy you
ever watched tombstone done holiday you
know I'll be your huckleberry even
though he Val Kilmer Val Kilmer you know
even though he fought with white art in
that movie right Doc Holliday wasn't a
great guy right gambler and so Doc
Holliday is probably my all-time
favorite villain in any movie of all
time so I do you consider him a villain
or a good guy well that's what we're
trying to figure out but you know Val
Kilmer's got kill in his last name so
you know he's made Kilmer Doc Holliday
number one for the win Alex were you Doc
Holliday in the NBA
I was not I'll be see that's what the
whole thing not everyone can wear the
white hat
why I grew up with rubbing Western
someone has to wear the black hat
there's got to be bad guys somewhere so
I was the val-kill I would Doc Holliday
of the NBA do you get blue Thursday
night in the garden I probably will the
[Music]
nerve of them booing anybody how the
Knicks have been the last 15 years they
are I just tell people they're cursed
never should have traded Patrick Ewing
to Seattle and never should have banned
Charles Oakley that's there's a car you
can't do that
there were two guys that were blue blood
hard-working that would do anything for
that organization you can't trade
Patrick Ewing to Seattle would you be
the best shooter on the next Thursday
night you would be I don't a reg great
to talk to you safe travels Thursday
night
it'll be Mavs and Knicks at the Garden
that'll be with Kevin Harlan and Allie
LaForce on TNT at 8:00 Eastern Thank You
reg I'll be your huckleberry baby that's
Reggie Miller for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]